les dangers grand damien tu les appelles
c
temporaires comme on se retrouve
tu te rappelles de thomas qui a traversé
le temps avec le robot kb 28 ou plutôt
eyliac comme il aime se faire appeler
monsieur ils sont à la recherche d'iris
et ça tombe bien car il la retrouve
saine et sauve assise sur un trône dans
un château au moyen-âge
pas le genre d'endroit au tueur croise
une ex n'est ce pas tu m'as lice thomas
qu'est ce que tu fous là donc toi toi
que tu fous là iris est bien un problème
attendez pourquoi le robot à café de mon
père et mon ex se retrouve au moyen-âge
dans mon château sans fait tellement
plaisir de voir et russe
mme harel connaissez vous ces intrus
vous voulez vous qu'on les élimine sur
le champ oui oui
non non non oui je les connais et non
les tubes arrivée qui est juste comme
lui d'autres époques plus inquiète pas
ma chérie tu ramènes en prison dans la
lah à thomas je voulais éviter cette
situation désolé d'interrompre les
retrouvailles irish
il y a un problème avec le docteur s'il
a tant qu'abbé 28 tu as dis quoi sans
mon père m'ont kidnappé ou tomber dans
une autre époque on s'en fout mais plus
important c'est que on est ensemble
je vous retourne chez nous dans thomas
on n'est plus ensemble here is war le
docteur simon a disparu cadets 28 c'est
normal que mon père ait disparu il
voyage dans le temps il a inventé la
machine il s'en sert sinon c'est con
thomas je sais que ça doit te faire un
choc mais oui je viens du futur et je
voyage d'époque en époque où je trouve
n'importe où et pas te le dire mais
plomb coup sa capacité à accepter le
voyage dans le temps est impressionnant
il faut de l'eau
c'est pas de l'osce et de l'autre vous
hérisse ton père a vraiment disparu tous
ceux qui voyagent laisse des traces
temporel on peut les localiser et voir
par où ils sont passés mais le docteur
simon plus rien impossible de savoir où
il est tu crois que mon père est est
décédé et ben moi je trouve que toi avec
ta robe de rennes / ressemble plutôt à
l'ordre m non je pense qu'il est encore
en vie j'ai été activée à distance par
ton père ou j'ai pensé que c'était pour
que je me serve à café je les chercher
mais il était introuvable au laboratoire
j'ai pris la dernière machine à voyager
dans le temps pour essayer de le
localiser
impossible alors je me suis dit que tu
savais peut-être où il était va-t-on
vers la statue qui brillera pas bouger
là vous avez un chevalier en armure
marraine jeu peut l'éliminer d'un coup
d'épée ce que vous voulez c'est très
tentant j'avoue mais non kb 28 je vais
vérifier dans l'histoire la machine à
voyager dans mes quartiers suis-moi mkb
il s'appelle elliott thabor sinon c'est
robot pob parce que je sais plus
pourquoi c'est pas une machine à qui on
donne des ordres
il y as tu peux me porter sur ton dos de
celui un peu plus son taux d'alcoolémie
est très élevé montrent thomas c'est
bien gentil machine j'ai pas de
nouvelles de mon père depuis un moment
tu sais qu'on s'entend pas très bien
peut-être que ma machine pourra
localiser plus facilement
[Musique]
aliénor en marraine ou vous ici tu fais
quoi ici tu dois nettoyer les latrines
pas ma chambre je fasse juste un coup de
plumeau rien de plus mais je m'en vais
là leur louche la dame lyrisme elle
tient la machine dans son dos j'en veux
te retrouves au micro à aliénor la sat
du d'aleris j'ai percé votre secret
c'est à cause de vous et de cet objet
magique que les malheurs sont tombés sur
mon mari wamen romain machine avant de
faire une connerie à vous a démuni
désormais je vais pouvoir récupérer mon
trône en pressant les boutons de cette
boîte magique al gore maintenant danie
royer l'homme était voué à genoux et
demandez moi partout pour l'injure que
vous avez porté à notre famille là bas
mais les partenaires l'alcool et c'était
les porter avec ma machine s'est écrié
nord de castille la reine du château
elle a les boules quand je suis arrivé
j'ai fait emprisonner le roi et je lui
ai filé angleterre vente et je regrette
parce que cette conne a pris ma machine
me suis bien fait pour ta gueule de la
chose un peu plus faites le taire j'ai
quelque chose qui peut le réveiller ah
oui c'est vrai que tu fais des cafés ça
va lui faire l'effet d'un coup de fouet
pour le taser c'est encore mieux
depuis quand elles savent que je me suis
ajouter cette fonctionnalité avant de
partir mais les lionnes tape une tueuse
signal
cappuccino volontiers c'est vraiment le
moment
bon un des cas pour moi très bien il ya
le dessin d'une fleur makrem semi merci
bon on va devoir utiliser ta machine
pour retrouver mon père est ce que tu as
des traces de lui avant sa disparition
puis il a beaucoup changé l'époque avant
de disparaître
mais j'ai tout enregistrer parfait voilà
ce qu'on va faire on se barre du moyen
âge on dépose thomas chez sa mère à son
époque où ensuite on suit les traces de
mon père on cherche des informations ce
qui faisait avec qui il échangeait
peut-être que ça nous mènera lui
conseille je rentre chez moi c'est
dangereux de voyager dans le temps et
trois rats je ne suis pas capable c'est
ça je peux être super utile et en même
temps on peut en profiter pour clarifier
notre situation c'est pas mal je vois
que tu t'en fous mon père et que tu veux
juste être avec moi à 7 on perd qu'on
cherche un peu oui j'étais bourré je
suis l'homme de la situation pour
retrouver ton père qui doit être
quelqu'un de très charmant c'est un
comble
comment tu parles du mambo bien désolé
de vous l'apprendre comme ça mais j'ai
plus assez de batteries pour voyager
dans le temps
ah non ne me dis pas qu on est coincé
ici j'ai puisé dans mes réserves
avec montazer voilà ça c'est une mission
pour moi tu vas voir je suis
indispensable
alors oui on peut savoir ce que tu fais
là cher méprise tout y'a pas de prise
ici on est en 1314 peut-être d'ailleurs
le lit alors je sais j'ai vu ça dans un
documentaire a t on pas sur le toit du
numérique en effet de l'orage on met un
câble entre l'antenne et il y est on
attend qu'il fasse un homme marié ça
c'est le film retour vers le futur
iris a tué à petit objet électronique ça
suffirait largement oui j'ai un
téléphone portable
je les filets au roi en échange de son
royaume il est dans les cachots la chine
sont royaux en échange d'un téléphone
pour envoyer des vidéos pornos dessus ça
l'a rendu dingue dès qu'il m'a filé sa
place je les fait emprisonner et j'ai
réduit la reine en esclavage on est
attendu tu regardes du porno uruguay où
toutes les filles les filles du futur
regard du porno les filles regardent du
porno mais l'un d'entre eux m'ont dit
soi non il faut frapper avant d'ouvrir
c'est moi ou le roi son pantalon baissé
parce que là je vois tout cela je dis
qu'il fallait frapper à la porte encore
merci marraine pour la pierre plate
magique qu'elle est si mal de fans qui
bourre est-ce qui peut remonter son
pantalon taché iris ce téléphone sera la
faire je veux voir les femmes sont en
proie à une crise et ont ému ce que tu
fais quoi découvrir les pornos et on est
privé juste après ce temps faire très
mal
alors hop et révoltés ils veulent votre
tête
mais pourquoi ils s'évadent d'un coup là
c'est une chanson qui reçoit puisqu'il
c'est la chanson de thomas oui c'est ma
chanson vous voyez je peux être utile je
n'ai gens m'écoutent pas du tout ils
veulent vous couper la tête mais je
déteste cette chanson en plus c'est en
partie pour ça que j'ai quitté ton
époque thomas a beaucoup nous toujours
ensemble c'est bon j'ai vite et la
batterie du téléphone on peut quitter
cette époque
enfin une bonne nouvelle mon cher voire
j'ai le plaisir de vous annoncer que
vous récupérez votre royaume
le royaume ne m'intéresse pas je veux la
pierre-plate avec les fans
les révolutionnaires il servir ils ont
déjà exécuté la moitié des châteaux où
ils vont pas démerdez-vous 1 nous on se
casse la b1 et iata oui allez mon père
j'ai quelque chose à berlin en 1944 non
bon bah c'est parti frémont milan
histoire oui bon ça va je ne lâche pas
dans le temps pour apprendre tous les
trucs mans il suffit d'aller à l'école
merde
elliott casse on nous tient le roi il
reste 2 % de batteries à mr
neuf sites à migrer bon on minus g
sacraliser la trace temporel du docteur
simon restait près de moi direction
l'allemagne recentralisation immédiate
bon bah c'est parti
oui c'est la guerre en fait bien vu mme
thomas c'est même la seconde guerre
mondiale comme on apprend dans le
programme de 4e désormais chers
auditeurs tu en sais plus sur la quête
d'elliot il faut retrouver le dr simon
inventeur de la machine à voyager dans
le temps montrent ils me retrouver
écoute le prochain épisode
moi je sais déjà tout eu les pires
mauroy rappeler à l'apport on vous
libère vous êtes libre tout va mieux
m'en désole vous avez votre pantalon
baissé
les images on en dise pas des fans où
sont les femmes